فكره انشاء حرس وطني في اسرائيل بدات
تختمر منذ عامين تقريبا بعد مواجهات ايار
مايو 2021 بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
في مناطق داخل الخط الاخضر وفي يونيو
الماضي اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
انذاك نفتالي بنت ووزير الامن الداخلي
والمدير العام للشرطه يعقوب شبتاي اطلاق
الحرس الاسرائيلي الذي يعرف ايضا باسم
الحرس الوطني والذي من المفترض ان يكون
ذراعا مسانده للشرطه الاسرائيليه
وبحسب مكان مخططا ستتشكل هذه القوه من
وحدات حرس الحدود التي ستتحول لفيلق للرد
السريع مع تجنيد الاف العناصر المدربين
وهذه النقطه بدات تثير مخاوف من استقطاب
مدنيين مسلحين الى صفوفها
ويتالف الحرس الوطني من القوه النظاميه
لحرس الحدود التي تضم ثمانيه الاف مقاتل
وست واربعين سريه احتياطيه تضم خمسه الاف
مقاتل و300 شرطي متطوع
وسيتولى الحرس الوطني القيام بمهام الرد
السريع في حاله الطوارئ تقديم استجابه
فوريه تجاه اي اضطرابات عامه والمساعده في
حالات الطوارئ والكوارث الطبيعيه
وستتيح هذه المهام للشرطه التفرغ بشكل
كامل لاداء مهامها التقليديه بحسب الخطه
الاولى لانشاء الحرس الوطني الذي من
المفترض ان يتبع هيكليا لقائد الشرطه وهنا
برزت المشكله مع الحكومه الحاليه
فوزير الامن القومي اتمد بنكير يريد للقوه
هذه ان تكون تحت امرته مباشره
واشترط اقرارها في الحكومه مقابل موافقته
على التمهل في التعديلات القضائيه وهو ما
حول المشروع الى نقطه جدليه بين الحكومه
التي يخيم عليها اقصى اليمين والمعارضه
التي ترى في حيازه بنكير للقوه هذه
تحويلها الى ميليشيا م من مستوطنين
متشددين جاهزين للعمل بامره متطرفين
مهووسين بحسب تعبير زعيم المعارضه
رغم ذلك اقرت الحكومه الاسرائيليه تخصيص
قرابه واحد وخمسه اعشار في المئه من
ميزانيه جميع الوزارات لتمويل الحرس
الوطني الذي سينشئ بميزانيه تصل للحو 111
مليون شيكل تحول كميزانيه لمره واحده على
ان تصل الميزانيه السنويه لنحو واحد وستين
مليون شيكل